mr speaker britain is set for lower
growth
than every major economy
except russia
why
prime minister
this is mr speaker i'll i'll tell him uh
mr speaker actually we are going to have
according to the imf and the oecd we are
in addition to the fastest growth in the
g7 last year we're going to have the
second fastest have the second fastest
this year and we will return to the top
of the table mr speaker but the reason
mr speaker uh other countries are
temporarily moving it is of course
because we came out of the pandemic
faster than they did
because we took the right decisions to
come out to come out of lockdown which
he opposed mr speaker and that's why
right now mr speaker we have the highest
number of people on payroll employment
on record
[Applause]
mr speaker he always likes to blame
global forces but global forces are just
that global everybody faces them
britain isn't prison under crippling
economic sanctions
like russia
no wonder he doesn't want to answer the
question why is the uk
set for lower growth than every other
major economy
mr speaker i i think i think everybody
can see that i've just answered the
question
what once once again once again he's get
he's guilty of what the legal friends
call ignorancio elenkai he's failed he's
failed to listen to what i've actually
said uh mr speaker what would be useful
in supporting the uk economy right now
would be if the leader of the labour
party ended his sphinx-like silence
about the rmt's strikes coming up in the
course of the next couple of weeks
will he will he now uh will he now break
with his shadow transport secretary and
denounce labour's rail strikes
he's in government
just to remind the primacy he seems to
have gone his primary question
[Applause]
he's in government he could do something
to stop the strikes but he hasn't lifted
a finger
i don't want the strikes to go ahead but
he does
he wants
mr speaker
he wants the country to grind to a halt
so he can feed off the division
[Applause]
mr speaker as for his boasting about the
economy
he thinks he can perform jedi mind
tricks on the country
these are the droids you're looking for
no rules were broken the economy is
booming
the problem is the force just isn't with
him anymore
[Applause]
he thinks he's obi-wan kenobi
the truth is he's jabber the heart
last week
last week he stood there and boasted
that we would continue to grow the
economy this week it turns out the
economy shrank for the second month in a
row
how does it help britain to have an
ostrich prime minister with his head in
the sand
[Applause]
there he goes again mr speaker running
running this country down
and when everybody we've got we've got
the highest we've got the highest
employment highest input
look i want to hear the questions and
the answers and
whether you like it but i genuinely
believe it the public could watch it
also once we're both prime minister
i mean mr speaker we've got lower
unemployment in france germany italy
canada uh we've got that we've got the
highest on people in payroll jobs as
i've just said and six hundred thousand
more since uh since records began uh and
he might like to know this uh that just
in the first five months of this year
this country has attracted i think 16
billion pounds of investment in its tech
sector
he doesn't like these european
comparisons let's make it for him three
times as much as germany twice as much
as france mr speaker he should be
talking this country up not running it
down
that's the ostrich
he's not just denying how bad things are
he's actively making things worse
his 15 tax rises are throttling growth
and the director of the cbi is so fed up
he's reduced to saying can we stop
operation say big dog
and move to action stations on the
economy
mr speaker
we know what the prime minister says
about british business in private
i think that's pretty um parliamentary
but when did screwing business turn from
a flippant comment into economic policy
well mr speaker i just i just reminded
the house of what's happening in in tech
week uh in this country the massive
investment that's coming in uh helped by
the way by this
130 percent super deduction for business
investment that my right old friend the
chancellor has put in never forget mr
speaker that labor under under labour
taxes go up on businesses and on people
and we're cutting we're not only putting
1200 more into people's pockets we're
having a tax cut worth 330 pounds he
talks about taxes 330 pounds on average
for everybody who pays national
insurance
labor have already made spending
commitments in this parliament alone
worth 94 billion pounds more than the
government that's 2
100 pounds for every household in the
country mr speaker no wonder no labour
government has ever left office with
unemployment lower than when they came
in
mr speaker 15 tax rises and we're sacked
for the highest tax burden since
rationing
he says the economy's booming when it's
shrinking he's he's game playing so much
he thinks he's on love island
trouble is
prime minister i'm reliably informed
that contestants that give the public
the ick get booted out
and it's it's not just low growth he's
also lost control of inflation he was
warned about this last september and
what did he do
he dismissed it he didn't act he sat on
his hands
now prices are through the roof
and we're set have the highest inflation
in the g7
when will he accept he got it badly
wrong when he claimed that worries about
inflation were unfounded
[Applause]
mr speaker we're helping people with the
cost of living with 1200 pounds on the
14th of july the money will be going
into people's bank accounts why can we
do that mr speaker because we have the
fiscal firepower to do it because the
economy is in robust shape uh with
record numbers of people in payroll
employment uh mr speaker and that is
thanks to the steps that we took that he
continuously opposed and if he wants to
and i just remind mr speaker he has a
chance i won't say this interrogatively
he has the chance now to clear it up uh
he can oppose the labour's rail strikes
right now safe
he can he can disagree he can disagree
and give him that opportunity
let him disagree with the union barons
who would add to people's costs in the
coming weeks
[Music]
mr speaker i don't want the strikes to
go ahead he does so he can feed on the
division
[Applause]
mr speaker
mr speaker
they're making a lot of noise now but
i've got a long list here of what his
mps really think of him
drag dragging everyone down who said
that
come on
who was it said that
authority authority is destroyed come on
hands up
which of you was it richard
can't win back trust anybody owning up
you're very quiet now hands hands
mr speaker mr speaker
my my personal favorite my personal
favorite is this this is a document
document circulated by his back bench in
which they call him
the conservative corbyn
prime minister i don't think that was
intended as a compliment
week after week
week after week
he stands there
and spouts the same nonsense the economy
is booming
everything's going swimmingly the people
should be grateful but whilst he's
telling britain that we never had it so
good millions of working people and
businesses know the reality
britain's growth is going to be slower
than our competitors and our inflation
higher
a prime minister who sounds totally
deluded
totally failing on the economy
[Applause]
i think we need to get to in the
question but in the
[Music]
but i'll just remind you i will hear the
end of the question in silence any more
noise in this corner it'll be another
cup of tea early if we're not careful
a prime minister who sounds totally
deluded totally failing the economy
failing to tackle inflation failing to
back business failing to help working
people through the crisis
and mr speaker
his big idea
go back to imperial measurements
he's got 80s inflation
70s stagnation now he wants 60s weights
to complete the set
when is he going to ditch the gimmicks
and face up to reality so under him
britain's economy is going backwards
[Applause]
let's see the prime minister the prime
minister
mr speaker
a couple of quick points about uh mr
corbyn uh right over his into north uh
first of all he tried repeatedly uh to
get him elected as prime minister
[Applause]
secondly speaking speaking from the
experience
he's relatively he's relatively dynamic
uh by comparison with the right
honourable gentleman
mr speaker dynamic and go here might be
able to speak to me i'm struggling to
hear because of the noise on both sides
so please if you if you
if you if you look to the tour it'll be
easy for both of us but what we're going
to get on and do mr speaker continue to
take the tough decisions to take this
country forward and
decisions that are on the side of the
british people mr speaker
they're blatantly on the side of the rmt
union barons
when when there are some ticket offices
that barely sell one ticket per hour mr
speaker we are on the side of the
traveling uh public
by the way he hasn't mentioned this but
they're on the side of the people
traffickers who would risk people's
lives and see mr speaker and we we are
on the side of people who come here
safely and legally
safely and legally mr speaker they cop
and
snipe from the sidelines that's what
they've always done we take the big
decisions to take this country forward
and no matter how much willy no matter
how much willing his right home repent
the deputy leader may ask him to apply
it doesn't matter how much willie he
potentially when that welly mr speaker
is always on the left foot
[Applause]